على منصه تيك توك بنشوف محتوى متنوع ويعني
ومشاهد وتحديات عجيبه غريبه بمجرد يعني من
بين المحتوى يعني هذا تحديات حتى خلينا
نقول عن تناول كميات كبيره من الطعام اللي
بتتعدى حاجه الشخص واحساسه بالشبع اللي او
الى التخمه يعني يعني بالعاميه كذا انه
بياكلوا بفجع يعني عارفين واللي بيعملوا
هذه التحديات اشخاص بمفردهم او بيكونوا
مثلا
ملايين المتابعين وملايين اللايكات على
تيك توك وفي منهم حتى تركوا اشغالهم
واعمالهم وصار شغلهم بس تحديات الاكل هذه
وبيكتبوا من وراها الملايين
ما ببالغ لما اقول ملايين لانه هاشتاجات
الموضوع عليها مليارات بالمئات مليارات
المشاهدات فيعني مثلا نقدر نلاقي واحد من
الهاشتاغات عليه 115 مليار مشاهده و مثلا
هذه
الهاشتاج هذا المقبق او مقبق للي ما يعرف
ايش معنى هي كلمه كوريه بتجمع كلمتين هم
الاكل والاذاعه ومع بعض صاروا كلمه واحده
بترمز لفيديوهات الناس اللي بتاكل فيها
وهي بتصور فيديوهات وبتتفاعل مع المتابعين
والغريب انه هذول الناس مستعدين يخربوا
صحتهم ويعرضوا حياتهم للخطر باستهلاك
الاكل هذا وكله فضل المشاهدات واللايكات
اللي
يحصلوا عليها ومن وقت انتشر هذا النوع من
المحتوى بشكل كبير وغزل منصه انطلقت
التحذيرات من خطورتها على الصحه وتسببها
بامراض من السمنه للسكري للقلب وغيرها
طبعا من المخاطر الصحيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صافي
[موسيقى]
سيره المخاطر الصحيه في اشخاص فقدوا
حياتهم بسبب هذا المحتوى والتحديات مثل
نجم تيك توك وفلر اللي بيملك ملايين
المتابعين واللايكات وكان معروف عنه انه
بيعمل تحديات غريبه وعجيبه عن الطعام
وبياكل كميات كبيره ومنها منتهيه الصلاحيه
حتى كمان كجزء من التحديات توفي عن عمر 33
عام بسكته قلبيه ويعتقد انه سبب الوفاء
كان مشاكل صحيه لها علاقه بين نمط حياته
وكل الاكل
ماكدونالدز
[موسيقى]